[Music]
let's go to anna in oklahoma city hey
anna what's going on
hi hi dr john thank you so much for
taking my call of course thank you for
calling how in the world are you
i'm i've had better days uh oh that's an
old uh 90s like pop rock song so let's
hear what's going on
well my husband and i are newlyweds and
we need help setting boundaries with my
parents oh sweet how long have you been
married
well we've only been married for about
four months now okay how's the first
four months going just y'all too
uh well great marriage is good with him
you still like him happy
oh yes
i fall deeper in him every day gross you
felt deeper in love with him yuck anna
now he's good all right good i'm falling
deeper in love every day hey i think
after four months my wife was like oh
geez
so good for you anna all right so what's
up how can i help you gotta uh you got
parent boundary issues yes yes tell me
about it what are your parents doing
this ought to be great
oh man well just to kind of give you
context my parents are very protective
overly protective and um just more over
the years i've seen how controlling they
are um
so when i was 18 years old i moved out
of my parents house and just got caught
up in the party lifestyle and
and drugs and so my parents saw that
you know along the way and i did that
for about eight years of my life and my
parents you know had a
i mean that was just hard for them to to
see that
over the years um
but anyway along the way around
25 years old i just kind of
came to the end of myself and met the
lord and
decided to you know turn my life around
went to school got a degree and match
for my bachelor's in biblical counseling
and started working with women um at a
drug rehab so i've been doing that for
years and then met my husband along the
way how old are you
i am 33. wow okay fantastic 23.
yeah so i met my husband along the way
and you know along you know these years
i haven't really dated
um
just because i hadn't met the right one
and so when i met my husband i just we
knew we just we knew that we were
supposed to be together gross ammo
i'm sorry
all right
so anyway i you know
once that happened i think my parents
expectations of how that was supposed to
look
um they wanted me to
to date for you know a couple of years i
guess before
marrying him
so
you know i talked to my parents i said
hey you know this man i know he's
supposed to be the one you know and so
they jumped on the bandwagon
and so
leading up to just planning the wedding
um
i had a discussion with my mom
about
just the finances and i said you know my
husband and i we're gonna pay for it you
guys don't have to worry or feel the
pressure about you know with the with
the wedding
um however my mom had said you know what
we're gonna go ahead and pay for it
we're gonna bless you guys
so with that being said uh
three weeks before our wedding
uh my mom said we're just gonna pay for
the cake
so i'm thinking are you kidding me
and i and she's like yes we we're just
gonna pay for the cake why'd she back
out and change your mind
yeah well when i asked her about it she
said well you misunderstood oh sweet and
i'm like are you i said mom i said this
is not about misunderstanding i said you
gave me your words i'm so happy
i'm not really happy
okay so so they gave you they just paid
for the cake and then by the time it
rolled around they paid for the straws
and the salt and pepper shakers and then
yeah then okay so you get you get
married and it's four months down the
road and
you're falling deeper in love every day
what are they
what are they doing how are they trying
to um exert control over you still
well so
well my parents
they
keep saying they don't know my husband
and they keep
so
just to back up my husband i tried to
set boundaries we met with them putting
them or making a bullet list of just
letters
um
or a letter of bullet points of things
that needed to be dressed
and so they shared it with the whole
family the letter that we had asked them
to keep confidential between all four of
us
what was in this what was in this letter
um so it was just boundaries basically
you know be kind and
um also we just said
we
we expect honesty
and we just shared our hearts and my
husband and i we just we sat down with
them we met with them because i'm from
the dallas fort worth area and now i
live in in oklahoma so we drove out
there just to talk to talk to them
and share our hearts with them about
everything that had happened leading up
to the wedding are they not are they
generally not kind are they i mean were
you addressing things that you had seen
or were you just
stating things okay so the things in
your letter the bullet points were
things
were behaviors and interactions and
relationships you guys had experienced
already yeah so i mean even when we're
yes to get your relationships off
and again you're not 18 you're 33 for
crying out loud right you've got your
own job he's got his own job y'all are
y'all experienced things and then you
said hey this is how we're gonna go and
get this off on the right foot
and you all bared your soul
and they went and told everybody
yeah well they said that they considered
it a threat
and
it was just it was unbelievable and i'm
thinking
okay
why did you guys even tell all my
brothers you know so now it's like
they they so now my brother called me
cussed me out for about 30 minutes and
said
you know you need to fix this you need
that you've betrayed the family
and so my mom called me and she said
anna you need to
come up to you know frisco and talk to
the whole family without your husband
and i'm like sorry so here here's the
deal here's the deal
yes you moved out at 18
yes
for a reason
yeah and
yes you did whatever you act like an 18
year old right and you acted like a 19
year old and a 20 year old here's my
guess
my guess is this type of
um
pitting brothers against sisters and
this type of lack of trust and this type
of immaturity and acting like a middle
school
with a with a power ego power trip has
been happening your whole life
and at 18 you went in search for some
sort of connection
and sleeping with people and alcohol and
drugs
are
chemically very similar to deep
connected relationships they're shorter
and they don't last as long and they
come with a ton of repercussions
yeah but they make sense okay yeah and
there's a reason why
college populations when you take a kid
who's been living at home even in a
messed up home and you pluck them from
everything they know and you send them
across the country and you drop them in
a box with a bunch of other 18 year olds
yeah that alcohol and
and sleeping with somebody
dude it just it makes you go
for a minute and then you gotta go do it
again the next day and do it again the
next day but you have young brains
screaming for a connection and you
didn't have that growing up you were
raised by children
and
now you're 33 right there's 10 11 12
years later
you circled back to include them
and once again
they haven't changed they're the same
people
and this is the heartbreak for you and
i'll i'll lay it out systematically okay
i'm gonna be honest with you cool cool
great good grand okay
and
um
you've grown up a lot
you saw the world a lot
right you've got experiences a lot and
here's the thing when you think back
between on your 18 to 25 times you did
stuff that you regret but you also
learned a lot and yeah i bet you met
some extraordinary people right yeah and
i bet you are more compassionate than
most of the people in your life right
yes
and you also realized uh there's a
there's just a more peaceful better way
to live right and so you've done hard
hard work on anna
and now you know what grace in a
relationship looks like and strength and
boundaries and connection and being
vulnerable you know what those things
are and you met a guy
who you're going deeper in love with
every day who shares that with you right
and by the way you know i'm joking here
right i'm like making faces you know i'm
kidding
i'm really excited for you
so here's the gonna be
the hardest thing you've ever done
yes it's gonna be killing that fantasy
that you can loot back and have it all
the way you wanted it to be
yeah
because what you're trying to do is
collapse the last however many years
and make it to where you're 25 and
you're getting married again and mom and
dad are involved in the wedding and your
brothers and your
new husband all hang out and go hunting
together and they play golf together and
they whatev and that's not going to
happen
yeah
i'm sorry
yeah because your parents are children
maybe your brothers have grown up
maybe your brothers are a little bit
different and mom and dad put them in an
unfair position to choose between them
and you
which really stinks
right
and maybe going to have a drink with
your brother going out some coffee with
your brother one one-on-one and saying
hey here's what we're doing man
and they know your mom and dad too
they know yeah right and they're either
reproducing that behavior in their
little families or they've grown up and
it's different and they got put in an
unfair position right is what it is
but at the end of the day you set up
your boundaries
and said here's what we expect we expect
people to be kind to each other to not
lie to us
um we want to have fun safe
laughter joy-filled holidays together we
want to come down to dallas but it's
like a five-hour drive we're gonna come
down to dallas and hang out with y'all
on the weekends but
here's the things and your parents
spit on your boundaries man
and that's what they're for
right to either be honored or set on
fire
and your parents pissed on yours and so
now you got the you got the message
right you got your aim yeah
and i hate that for you so here's what
you got to do
you're going to have to be highly
intentional arou about being around
adult couples who are older than you and
wiser than you
and forming some sort of surrogate
relationships with couples who are 10
years down the road
who you and your husband will go hang
out with have coffee with
go i don't know whatever you do in
oklahoma i just feel like oklahoma's a
state of sadness and so i don't know
i'm just kidding it's a great place to
live all texans are raised to think like
if you go to oklahoma it all ends right
but i understand what you're doing and
you're proselytizing so you're spreading
the will of texas up into the north and
i appreciate that but you're gonna have
to find some families um who are going
to be
the grown-up
wise people who love you and love your
husband and invest in you all that your
parents should be but are not
but aren't
if i'm you i would reach out to my
brothers one on one and by the way two
important things nobody cusses me out
for 30 minutes
they cuss me out for one second because
then i hang up the phone not gonna hear
that i'm not gonna listen to that
at all
and i'll tell another grown-up when
you're ready to talk like a grown-up
we'll have a conversation but i'm out
and then maybe a week later two weeks
later for somebody i love i'll reach
back out and say you ready to talk like
a grown-up and if they're not then i'm
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna do that i'm
just not
the challenge for you is and the second
challenge is for you to not give over
your integrity not get over over the
growth you've had to try to
crawl back and
make them okay
i want you and your husband to get the
book um
dad i just i forget the title every time
you know this one james
it's
it's parents it's children of
emotionally adult
children of emotionally immature parents
who wrote that book
it's right there
susan gibson is at it
lindsay gibson so
anna i want you to get you and your
husband to get the book adult children
of emotionally immature parents
by dr gibson gibson it's a masterpiece
it's really thin it's wonderful you'll
probably end up highlighting more of the
book than not i want you all to work
through that together
and then i want you to reassess your
boundaries reassess who you all want to
be as a couple where are you all going
to go what's the picture of what your
marriage is going to look like and
you'll live into that your parents have
opted out
and you all have to agree
it's heartbreaking i hate it for you
i hate it for you
and hopefully your brothers won't opt
out
nothing was worse than getting burned by
two people who said we're supposed to
love you and by the way
you broke their heart when they're 18 19
20. so it's true
but they have chosen to not grow with
you they've chosen to be frozen
and i'm a rapper now because i just
rhymed chosen and frozen um they've
chosen to remain frozen in their
maturity and their love for you it's
still conditional it's still got strings
it's still got moves it's still got like
still keeping you guys off kilter and
here you all are 33 you got both feet on
the ground
go find a couple today man go find a
couple and reach out and start that
healing process with new people man i'm
so so sorry for you